[Applaudissements]
le 14
et après treize ans de périple la sonde
spatiale voyager loin arrive aux confins
de notre système solaire aux frontières
dans notre système solaire elle tourner
sa caméra une dernière fois vers la
terre prend une photo qui sera connu
sous le nom paye le lot un point bleu
pâle français vous voyez ce petit point
là ça c'est la terre c'est nous d'une
telle distance à 6 4 milliards de
kilomètres
on voit la terre minuscule un film d'ici
là vu tellement sereine tellement simple
mais de là où nous sommes à ce aussi
simple aussi sereine aussi paisible je
ne pense pas du tout
car faut savoir que cette terre héberge
7 8 6 milliards d'êtres humains en plus
de 2 milliards en 18 ans et moins et
plus récemment les habitants de cette
terre ont connu un boom technologique
qui est venu bouleverser leur façon de
vivre
savez vous que l'impact de l'avancement
scientifique hayon lieux en quelques
mois aujourd'hui équivalent à l'impact
de l'avancement scientifique sur plus de
dizaines d'années auparavant
et cet impact a des conséquences énormes
sur le marché de travail des métiers qui
disparaissent de nouveaux métiers qui
apparaissent des métiers qui suit
modifie qui évolue et ça se passe
tellement vite qu'on a du mal à suivre
et qui est perdu dans ce chamboulement
les jeunes qui se pose la question
qu'est ce que je veux faire plus tard
dans ma vie quels sont les métiers qui
vont me rendre heureux c'est une
question qu'on se pose dès l'enfance et
on change énormément d'avis
personnellement ce que je voulais être
quand j'étais enfant pas au départ
je voulais être comme mes parents
ingénieur civil et comptables les deux
métiers en même temps ensuite je
commençais à regarder minus et cortex
pink and planes et en fait j'ai décidé
de devenir le président du monde
après quelques années je vu que en fait
c'est un petit peu compliqué donc je me
suis dit allez le président de la
république libanaise seulement régime
taliban et ensuite je commençais à
regarder le laboratoire de dexter je
voulais comme lui avoir un laboratoire
secret sont ma chambre ce qui était
impossible vu que j'habitais dans un
appartement du 6e étage ne pouvais plus
je ne pouvais pas creuser coup et je me
suis même vu berger
car à chaque fois que je voyais le
berger de mon village avec ses moutons
je me disais que cet homme il a l'air
plus heureux que la plupart de gens en
costard cravate que je voyais dans les
rues de beyrouth et à la fin je fais
aucun de ses métiers car il arrive un
moment dans la vie on doit prendre une
décision sur quelles filières quelle
spécialisation
quel parcours et cette décision elle
fait peur car on voit le champ des
possibilités pour nous se réduire en
général l'orientation scolaire est le
résultat de l'influencé de plusieurs
facteurs la vie de nos proches la
situation financière et l'environnement
social et souvent on fait comment on
demande l'avis d'une approche donc nos
parents nos profs
nos amis ont fait des tests de
personnalité on a tous fait le problème
avec ces tests que on a souvent tendance
à répondre parce qu'on aimerait être et
non en fonction de ce qu'on est vraiment
on fait des sciences des suivis avec un
conseiller d'orientation vous savez
cette figure mythique de l'école qui va
essayer de me poser des questions pour
essayer de comprendre ma personnalité
ensuite me proposer des métiers certes
certes ça peut marcher pour les gens
extravertis ouvert mais pour beaucoup
d'entre nous on va pas vouloir ou même
savoir comment dévoiler notre
personnalité en hausse intérêt car nous
même surtout quand on est jeune on n'a
pas nécessairement la réponse à la
question qui suis-je
et malgré sincèrement malgré tout le
respect que j'ai envers les conseils
d'orientation et leur très très bonne
volonté mais moi même personnellement
dans mon propre domaine d'étude et de
travail
j'ai du mal à suivre des nouveautés les
technologies les spécialisations
nouvelles spécialisations les filières
qui apparaissent dans mon propre domaine
donc comment un conseiller d'orientation
peut-il tout suivre dans tous les
domaines c'est juste impossible donc les
conseillers d'orientation aurait
peut-être même besoin d'un conseiller
non mais pas forcément humain car ça
dépasse notre capacité à stimulation
d'informations donc sous quelle forme
l'intelligence artificielle donc l'idée
est venue petit à petit à petit en
discutant avec mes étudiants à
l'université pendant des années dans
chaque classe je voyais de quelques
étudiants des motifs et découragé avant
durant et après le court ils ont 18 ans
ils ont vingt ans le monde est devant il
ne le voit pas donc j'ai très vite
compris que la cause de leur doute
n'hésitez pas dans leur choix de
formation mais dans la crainte d'accéder
à un métier qui leur correspondent pas
donc en fait ils disaient enfin il pense
être passé à côté de meilleure option
ils pensent avoir déjà raté leur vie et
ils disaient que c'était parce qu'ils
n'ont pas eu assez d'informations au
départ je ne comprenais pas comment est
ce possible
vous avez google quoi vous avez tous sur
internet
mais après j'ai en fait ce que j'avais
passéiste que oui justement c'est ça le
problème
il y a trop d'informations imaginez avec
moi un étudiant à la recherche du métier
qui lui plairait c'est comme s'il était
perdu dans une galaxie des toiles tels
que chaque étoile correspondant à un
métier ou une formation
imaginez maintenant si je vous demande
de vous couvrir une telle claque si et
de choisir la plus belle étoile
ce écologiquement le fait que vous ne
voyez pas la limite de cette galaxie
s'avoue des motifs
car même si vous trouvez une belle
étoile un métier que vous aimez bien y
aura toujours une once de doute qui vous
ronge de l'intérieur qui vous fait
sentir que peut-être il ya une étoile un
métier que vous n'avez pas vu qui est
encore mieux que ça lui que vous avez
choisi et c'est ce doute là que vous
faire regarder en arrière c'est ce doute
là qui vous fait dépenser votre énergie
20 noms au lieu de foncer vers ce métier
donc imaginez maintenant si je prends
toutes ces étoiles et que je les
rassemble dans un cercle qui ressemble à
la terre et que je les met entre vos
mains vous voyez comme la chanson en
anglais you've got the whole world
voici la galaxie des métiers un moteur
de recherche interactive qui vous permet
d'explorer des centaines d'émeutiers à
l'aide d'une interface simple et ludique
chaque petit star qui correspondent à un
métier que vous pouvez explorer c'est
une expérience immersive d'un enjeu est
de fournir une information de qualité
sur les métiers avec la possible avec la
possibilité de les filtrer par salaires
salaires de début pour être plus précis
niveau d'études requis
là par exemple le bac + 3 et bac + 4 à
bac + 5 centres d'intérêts j'ai manqué d
analyser l'information je pourrais
vendre n'importe quoi rester toute la
journée derrière un bureau no mercy et
acteurs professionnels et on a ajouté un
cinquième filtre spécial lady cet
objectif de développement durable ce
qu'on appelle les 17 au d'été vous savez
ce que sont les autres les dix sept
objectifs de développement durable sont
des objectifs qui réunissent tous les
pays du monde afin de l'éradiquer la
peau verte et sauver la planète et faire
en sorte que tous les êtres humains
vivent dans la paix à la prospérité
ces deux objectifs à atteindre d'ici
2030 pour les pays du monde
donc j'ai pensé avec borne à albi ce jeu
vous lire les magnifiques amis avec qui
je fais cette galaxie que ça serait
génial si on peut aider les jeunes dans
leur quête de sens de donner du sens à
chaque métier
comment en essayant de rallier les
métiers avec ses objectifs de
développement durable
donc on a décidé de partir à la chasse
d'histoire qui inspire et pour chaque
métier on a sillonné l'internet à la
recherche de contenus articles ou vidéo
qui raconte l'histoire des gens qui ont
à travers leur métier contribué à au
moins un au dd c'est comme ça c'est à
travers ces histoires qu'on a pu relier
les métiers avec les eaux dd c'était un
an de travail de recherche pour
construire les bases de données mais ça
valait vraiment vraiment la panne est
maintenant est-ce que vous avez remarqué
quelque chose je parle toujours des
métiers et pas de formation imaginez un
nouveau avec moi un arbre qui est loin
qui représente un métier à la vidéo
voilà il
avec moi un arbre qui représente un
métier donc si vous concentrer sur cet
arbre et vous marchez vers star dans
votre tête tous les obstacles entre vous
et cet arbre devient moins importante
les pierres et le rush devient plus
petit le court difficile
les profs exigeons les choses que vous
êtes obligés d'apprendre que vous voulez
pas à prendre tout ça ça devient moins
important car vous voyez la finalité
c'est le métier vous voulez y arriver
c'est pour ça viser un métier et pas une
formation et si vous avez déjà entamé
une formation qui m'aiment pas à ce
métier
ben vous inquiétez pas il ya des
passerelles partout plus que vous
imaginez revenons maintenant à la
galaxie des métiers donc jusqu'à
maintenant de là où nous sommes
c'est un outil simple où on peut
naviguer librement mais parfois on a
besoin de là d'un coup de pouce d'une
vraie proposition est celle à l'utilité
de l'intelligence artificielle
donc l'idée est la suivante si je
regarde le comportement de la personne
de la personne sur galaxy comment il est
en train de l'utiliser
les métiers qu'il est en train de
regarder regarder à nouveau les filtres
qu'il en train d'utiliser les temps
passé sur chaque fiche métier ou live là
où il s'intéresse le plus il tique le
plus si je prends toutes ces
informations et bien d'autres
je les analyse avec des algorithmes
spéciaux de big data je peux comprendre
deux choses soit la personne sur ses
intérêts ses préférences qu'ils aiment
ce qu'ils n'aiment pas ensuite j'utilise
ces informations pour lui proposer des
métiers qui peuvent l'intéresser
la proposition ciblée et ensuite après
chaque proposition du métier je lui
demande son avis qui est la même ou pas
et je n'utilise son feedback ce retour
comme un paramètre supplémentaire pour
affiner améliorer encore plus la
performance des algorithmes pour que ce
soit plus précis ça c'est l'intelligence
artificielle vous voyez c'est un
conseiller d'orientation les différents
soyons clair le but ce n'est pas de
remplacer le conseiller d'orientation
est supprimé à leur travail
pas du tout la galaxie des métiers oui
vous propose des métiers mais elle ne
peut pas entamer une discussion sur ces
métiers avec vous
à mon avis il ya rien qui remplace
l'intelligence émotionnelle et social
des humains le profondeur d'une voix
rassurante la chaleur d'un sourire
attentive et sincère pensait de ce
statut tant que membre à intelligent qui
peut aider les conseillers d'orientation
à mieux faire leur travail qui leur
fournissent des informations de façon
dynamique et qui les aident à mieux
comprendre les réelles préférence des
étudiants en face d'eux un bras
intelligent si complet avec un sourire
et le bon rapport humain peut rendre
l'expérience de l'orientation scolaire
plus efficace et plus adaptées à la
société et un marché de travail qui
évolue en permanence
revenons maintenant sur ton de la terre
et revenons sur cette image dans cette
image on voit connaît qu'une particule
un attendent dans un univers infini
nous n'oublions pas chacun de nous
chacun de vous est une galaxie d'atomes
lui même et si on trouve le métier avec
du sens qui nous épanouie qui nous donne
envie de se réveiller le matin
cette galaxie à l'intérieur de chacun de
nous sera pleine de aurore boréale des
bulles et de supernova de toutes les
belles couleurs lumières imaginables et
cette lumière embryons si fort peut-être
peux aider les autres
éclairer le chemin deux autres pour
qu'ils trouvent même pour qu'ils
trouvent leur voie dans l'obscurité pour
qu'ils trouvent eux-mêmes leur propre
lumière sont l'intelligence artificielle
l'orientation scolaire avec les méthodes
actuelles ne pourra pas résister un
futur aussi changé et c'est un sujet
majeur car n'oublions pas que la mission
du conseil est lorsqu'il aide un jeune a
trouvé sa voie
c'est de faire en sorte qu'ils soient
épanouis dans instance dans sa vie
professionnelle
c'est le reflet
une envie de construire une société
heureuse de productive et si on arrive à
réaliser ça a bien orienter les jeunes
vers les métiers qui les font briller on
construit un véritable phare humains
pour encourager les autres pour les
inspirer et leur donner envie et si on
arrive à réaliser ça c'est à ce moment
là qu'on pourra vraiment dire qu'on
avait inventé l'orientation scolaire
merci
[Applaudissements]